we've spoken before on the program about
Lara Logan Lara Logan is a
she at least was a journalist and she
did some really good work when she was
with 60 minutes
something happened to Lara Logan and I
know that many say David what happened
is she was brutally assaulted when uh um
doing coverage in the Middle East and
she has PTSD that's what hap maybe it is
I I don't know something happened to
Lara Logan where she is now on Fox
Nation repeating some of the most rancid
conspiracy theories that we have seen in
the political media space for the last
10 years and most recently Lara Logan
suggested that darwinian Evolution may
be a hoax funded by Jews now she for a
while now has been using some of these
anti-semitic tropes and talking points
of a globalist you almost when you hear
the word globalist you almost have to
say globalished like Alex Jones
globalist stuff
Rothschild all these different things
she appeared on
honestly I don't even know what this is
it's a show called and we know
and she suggested
that darwinian Evolution may be a Jewish
funded hoax listen to this so now you've
gone from being a farmer who may not be
able to farm efficiently who may not be
able to feed as many people but guess
what
he could feed he could grow food year
after year after year because who
created seeds that are renewable like
truly like who created life that is
truly renewable what is the only thing
on earth that is actually renewable
it's life
and they can you know go back to the Big
Bang Theory and Darwin I mean when I
found out does anyone know when who
employed Darwin where Darwinism comes
from
yeah go ahead
well I mean you know look it up the
Rothschilds yeah it goes right back to
10 Downing Street all the way oh boy the
same people who employed Darwin and
that's when Darwin you know wrote his
theory of evolution and so on and so on
guys did did you know that
you know Dart what what she's suggesting
here is
the theory of darwinian evolution didn't
come from Darwin doing real science
Jews the Rothschilds hired Darwin
and then all of a sudden he writes this
theory of evolution and then
what and I'm not saying that none of
that is true I'm just saying Darwin was
hired by someone to come up with a
theory right based on evidence okay fine
but you know even the people fine I
guess it was based on evidence well the
scientists all of the people that can
take you back to the Big Bang what is
the one question they can never ever
ever answer they can never tell you
whatever that was whether it's the
molecules or the energy or you know all
that stuff all these scientists like
that you know that evil uh horrible
person who's the science advisor to
Claus Schwab at the world economic forum
who says there's no such thing as
Freedom every there's no such you know
there's Randomness but that's not
freedom and blah blah blah it's a
probability and there's this and there's
that they can explain it away any way
you like but how did those things come
into being you know and it was it was a
combination of
it's that question of what came first
the chicken or the egg right you can't
answer that scientifically now as many
of you already know this is an often
this is a sort of God of the gaps
hypothesis or talking point which is any
phenomena that cannot yet be answered by
science or maybe never will but it
doesn't make a difference
you put God into those gaps so we we
don't know now what was there before
everything I mean it's a very
complicated question it's a scientific
question it's a philosophical question
it's it's a big question
that doesn't mean you know it's Jesus or
Zeus or whatever there's there's no
evidence for that when it comes to Lara
Logan first of all this is this is
disgusting right I mean Jews funded the
The hoax of darwinian evolution even if
it was maybe based in some fact that's
her idea
um do you think that she started
believing this stuff so then Fox hired
her or is it that fox hired her
and it got her to start spouting this
stuff it's hard to say which way it goes
and there may be some some way in which
it's both but this is a real life
cautionary tale about a lot of different
things about how right-wing media will
rot your brain and listen if PTSD is
part of what's going on with Larry Logan
it's a cautionary tale about that as
well and it's not for any of us to
diagnose what's going on but I feel it
relevant to mention that she did suffer
an insane situation and not long after
that these have started to be her ideas
so make of it what you will uh no
comment from Fox about these completely
outrageous comments by Lara Logan